I think I still got some healing to do
cuz I'll never let my mom win just yet
even if the egg was right no like even
like when we like I'll grab dinner with
her and she's like can you walk with
Mommy uh back to like the the house
because it's dark and Mommy's scared or
whatever I'm like sure and I'll walk out
like this I'll protect you and then all
the neighbors are like why is that grown
dude like pretending like I'm like I'll
protect you Mom oh there's bad guys
everywhere you stop
it
welcome back to careful boys we in the
new office oh wow thank you Ryan thank
you Ryan and smack and AIS for carrying
a few things and Anthony for kind of
supervising being the ideas guy foran
he's a foran or Anthony to complain
about the filth and this office for six
months straight till we had to do
something about it got the ball rolling
he he thre to call OSHA really is what
happened I know he was going to call
I know um so what is the worst advice
you have ever been given aside from the
ones that Anthony gives us yeah other
than Anthony that's what the promise is
aside from Anthony Lee what's the worst
advice you he's writing it it aside from
the first one that comes to mind isn't
really the worst advice but I think it's
how it's used and it's uh follow your
gut so if you I think but if your gut is
stupid exactly so I think you need to
look at your own track record and if you
have like five wins like like that's
like your track record is pretty good
yeah maybe follow your gut but if you
keep getting into [__] situations you
should follow someone else's gut that's
been
winning yeah true mine is um don't you
know do business with friends and family
and it's to me it's been the opposite
like the friends and family part is
actually the best part strangers is
actually the wor worst part why is that
what's no trust yeah I don't know like I
think if you think about the people
that's probably [__] you over it's
always strangers not your friends and
family in my case at least but I don't
know luy when people say that it's like
I think you know they they they got
screwed over by their own friends and
family and I'm all like well you have
shitty friends and family you you chose
bad yeah but I think all of my companies
are with people that I've known for over
decades
alls all friends all family um I don't
know and sure there's like certain
disagreements but for the most part it's
been great so I don't know like where
that comes from it's probably just from
people that have shitty family members
probably do you know what I think uh
it's not the worst advice it it is
pretty bad advice it's like for
relationship stuff when people go oh you
know at the 3mon Mark or 6 month Mark a
b or c should happen and then one year
like the Milestones it's like by the
seventh year you're going to face this
and it's like no you don't shut the [__]
up it is so stupid so generic too yeah
it's like Oh by one year if you don't
like them then you shouldn't date them
cuz if if we follow if me and Hannah
followed any of those rules we probably
wouldn't be together yeah cuz we broke
all of them all all the red flags most
good relationships break those do they
still have that rule where like you get
a number and you don't wait you wait 3
days or some
[__] oh that's that you got to do that
you got to do that you got that thing
it's like you don't to be S thirsty you
got to wait 3 days before you text them
or some [__] old that's so funny people
would say that [__] about like me and
Tiff they're like you're going to marry
your high school sweetheart and [__] but
I'm like that's the dopest thing ever
yeah but at the same time like I get
where they're coming from cuz it's like
you got to see the world you got to
[__] like people yeah but at the same
time it's
like I think you're [__] a little
bit right yeah it is [__] I think
you need it's so circumstantial I think
you need to see the world if you don't
know what you want yeah but if you
already know what want and you have what
you want then like one of the most
amazing things for like the last decade
for me is once you're with someone it's
like that part of your life is filled
and then now you're building yeah you're
building a marriage you're building a
family whatever doing you're doing
everything together versus you're still
like shopping around shopping around you
know yeah cuz we got to a point where we
realize we wanted the same things and
then from there it's just like the hard
work to like build it as you go up like
I think that was the important thing but
yeah so many people give you advice when
it comes well they're idiots well comes
from like their own view of the world
and it doesn't really it doesn't apply
to you yeah it doesn't take your life
into account I think that's usually bad
advice cuz they might be thinking man
Nick I want 50 more [__] before I get
and settled down and then you're just
like what what I'm not like a sex I wish
I can get 50 50 is the same I want 50
more [__] before I get
married yeah some people think they need
that people oh yeah that's the common
thing everyone says people used to be
like oh you're going to be a you're
going to be a trainer you're going to be
a [__] Co coach or some [__] like
they would like kind of talk down like
that when I why well just because like
that's weird weird you're going to
improve People's Health and lives are
you a stupid but but once again it's
from people who are like not doing that
stuff like when I was in school I went
to school for uh exerise science and a
lot of people that were doing that were
um wanted to be on track for physical
therapy and at the time I was like yeah
that's cool but I think I'd rather just
want to like train people or whatever
like cuz that was like my passion or
whatever and then people were like oh
you're going to do that instead like oh
it doesn't really seem very safe BL they
have all their own preconceived notions
about that profession and then they like
kind of dump it on you and then you're
like [__] am I am I tripping should I do
something else you know yeah that's
what's hard hearing someone talk when
they can't see themselves in your place
exactly and so they give you bad advice
or they tell you you should do X Y and Z
and it's like well that's not the life
that I want to live or whatever the case
may be that's why I never listen to my
parents oh dude that's the worst yo you
know what the worst advice is is when
somebody tells you how to do something
something like for example hey this is
how you make a lot of money but then
it's coming from a person who has zero
money that's like wait what let me tell
you something yeah yeah that always
happens with like different things not
just money that's like the fat personal
trainer yeah you want workout advice
that's I do I think you should work out
oh you know what I think the worst is
take a LP Bud yeah doctors oh because
they're well respected in their field
and they know their [__] like in in
medical you know like or whatever maybe
not all of them do but use that title as
if they're an expert on everything it's
like don't worry I'm a doctor and it's
like you don't know anything about
[__] hip-hop dance what the [__] like
how the [__] hold up Dr Dre
does like my mom she got diagnosed with
osteoporosis and uh wor a bunch of their
Specialists were like oh you need to be
doing these drugs like you need to come
in we'll give you an injection to your
spine blah blah go and then and then
meanwhile she has her friends being like
oh you shouldn't be lifting weights you
shouldn't be doing all stuff you're
going to hurt yourself lifting weights
is the best thing for osteoporosis
that's what I mean and it's like you
listen to doctors who are in the know
who are like like they work in the field
yeah like the ones that actually work
with longevity Specialists or like maybe
like uh people who are working with
people that have osteoporosis and a
[__] dentist comes by and says I
don't think you should do that yeah
exactly to your feet and then they give
you all this and it's it's hard cuz my
mom's like what should I do what should
I do I'm like [__] just keep lifting
weights do all things how about listen
to the people in the field that are at
the [__] Cutting Edge like they have
the we experiencing this yeah they have
the most experience you know what's
worse than a doctor is just somebody
with a doctorate oh like a
PhD I have a pH not not that everybody
in journalism but just the people that
point it out to you it's like it's
always a bad sign when they're like oh
you know I have a doctorate and it's not
even close to being yo did you see that
Jubilee video where that the PHD girl
she had the lowest
IQ and she's bomb thr and then the
military guy had the highest right yeah
God and she told she told him that he
had the lowest well the well the highest
the guy with the highest IQ in the
Guinness worldo Records is a bouncer no
way yeah he's he's like a [__] genius
right he developed some framework for
like it's it's some quantum physics [__]
about like how he views like God or
whatever it's some crazy [__] holy [__]
profession and he Chucks people out of
the club yeah he's a bouncer and then he
lives isolated on a farm that's [__]
from like like a club
bouncer on a farm yeah well I guess he
drives to the city you know why's yeah
Road no he's a he's actually a big brain
boy because he doesn't have to do any
[__] work being a bouncer for for a
town for a town of 500 people what do
you got to do a club bouncer he gets to
lift weights and just throw people out
Carlton style one Jazzy Jeff style one
of the worst advice that I I still get
to this day
um it's just so broad it's just like go
back to school or finish school oh bro
what a [__] random ass people anytime
go toool anytime like we're talking
about school with anybody and I go like
oh yeah I had a quarter left of UCI and
then I dropped out to do dance they're
like oh you should go back and finish it
at this point for literary journalism so
I can work at the New York Times like
what what's the dream that's how you
know when someone's stupid when when uh
they give absolute conclusions with zero
Contex yeah because that's such an
Absolution they just say it they jump to
the conclusion or they hear us talking
like R Ryan's talking right now and like
he clearly wants to finish school he's
just
afraid yeah like you know for a fact
right you know for a fact you're not
even in this room by the way because I
don't even I don't even think school is
bad I just think like once once you
figured out what you're going to do you
don't need it anymore it's like you're
fine dude well it's cuz they used to
have a monopoly on education and that
was the only way that you can kind of
find a space for that but now it's like
this episode is brought to you by
DraftKings DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL playoffs is bringing you an offer
that will make the playoffs more
electrifying new customers can bet five
bucks on any game and get 200 instantly
in bonus bets check it out scroll scroll
look at these teams look at these odds
of this week scroll scroll scroll oh
yeah so download the draftking
Sportsbook app now use the code off the
Record new customers can just bet five
bucks and get 200 bucks instantly in
bonus bets only on draft King Sportsbook
with code off the Record the crown is
yours thank you DraftKings gambling
problem call 1800 Gambler or visit www.1
1800 gambler. net in New York call 8778
Hope NY or text Hope NY
46739 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call
8887895118 possibly on behalf of Boot
Hill Casino and Resort in Kansas 21 plus
age varies by jurisdiction void in
Ontario bonus bets expire 168 hours
after issuance see dk.com for
eligibility and deposit restrictions
terms and responsible gaming resources
you can have one-on ones you can have
Master like mindes or what's that master
class from actual professionals you
could learn directly from like Michael
Jordan
himself on basketball I mean it's also
I'm not trying to get one of those
corporate jobs that requires like a
specific diploma it's like I don't work
in that field but then people are still
like no you you should finish it just in
case I can't believe people tell you
that dude I'm not going to get a that
type of job at this age either it's like
I have to be an entrepreneur Dam that's
crazy I got a buddy who's like going
through a divorce right now and then I
got another buddy who's like all right
dude here's the first thing you got to
do oh no oh no and then he's like you
got to start slaying every [__] [__]
in town and all that [__] that's not bad
advice right he just wants to live like
yeah that's a vicarious advice yeah why
why it's not his dick it's vicarious
bait or he I really do think he thinks
it's like the best advice ever or he
wants to go through a divorce too but he
can't yet yeah this is what I would do
so when I was with him when I was with
them both I was like I was like that's
really bad advice dude I was like cuz
cuz you don't know what he wants like
and he's not the type of guy who wants
to go [__] he's like a nerd he
doesn't want to go want to go slay [__]
and [__] like that but that's why he
should go cuz he's a nerd oh he need
transform he wear the other jackets
slick back hair come on yeah he should
have been like you need to go to
Thailand and get your lady boys that you
always
wanted that's what he wants he's
projecting it onto him you know you want
to be with a lady boy real bad just
admit it already wait what yeah it is
bad advice it's bad advice you don't
know what well you have to know what
they're what that's the first thing I
always ask people it's like what do you
want yeah cuz I don't know I don't know
I don't even really know for sure when
that is good advice like to just go
slate puss [__] a lot of [__] I don't
even know when that's truly good advice
I think it's good advice if you're truly
heartbroken and like you're there's just
no you have no um you know no emotional
support anywhere I think it's fine to
just like go ahead and Scatter your
[__] heart into a million pieces for
a while so that you can use the numbness
to like build yourself back up that's
what I think it works what about if
you're in Amsterdam go slay some puss
then probably doesn't have to be a sad
time when I was there I saw some
Japanese school kids like not kids like
[__] college kids running around and
having the time of their life and one of
my favorite things to do is just ease
drop on what they were saying what were
they saying they were like oh my God
that one look and then there's like a
dweeb in the group and they're like look
she's calling you and then she's like
doing this and he goes oh no that one's
too much woman for me I can't handle her
have a sitcom yeah and he goes no I need
someone less intimidating and they're
like come on man do it when when you
ever going to have a foreigner like that
and then I'm just listening like and
then lady's like a like 58 like woman
you know and then this dude's like a 53
like dweeb and then I I actually wanted
to see it go down but she was like yeah
but it's like it's that to me is like
when you're at a video game shop and
they Mis price all the games and you're
like I can't believe all these games are
so
cheap I'm on a deal I could get them
all what the [__] cuz when I was there I
was like it's
$60 everybody's a 10 yeah like that was
insane pretty crazy it is pretty crazy
like $60 for like the hottest chick
you've ever seen but it's not the same
when they don't want you well you got to
pay you pay double and they want you
okay that's true well what's some bad
advice you could give someone going to
Amsterdam and doing that bad advice
don't get a
hooker that's really that's good but
even that question it goes back to what
do you want right I think bad advice is
in general is not the advice itself but
who's giving the advice and who's
receiving the advice yeah I think bad
advice is horrible outcomes yeah it's
like people what's the goal and if you
get the opposite of that goal or not
anywhere close I think a lot of people
just suck at life because they don't
understand that this action will cause
this reaction so it's like they have bad
predictions and so they think this is
what's going to happen they got bad guts
exactly horrible guts it goes kind of
Full Circle to what BART said you guys
ever meet somebody that just has like
they complain about their their
circumstances all the time where like
relationships oh I cut them off they
they complain about all the time all the
time all the time and then you ask them
simply like what do you want out of this
situ like what do you want for yourself
and they're just like H like they have
no [__] idea yeah they won't complain
yeah they they're just kind of like in
limbo and they haven't even thought
about that or when they give you their
explanation of what they want it's like
the most vague kind of surface level
stuff and when you give them solutions
they start giving you excuses and then
next week they're going to complain
about the same [__] [__] to you
again and it's like every day I'm like
bro same thing same thing if not the
situations worse like this is tough like
you know you know what it is for me too
I think some of the some of the worst
advice is is advice that's just way too
complicated I think like I think first
you got to do this then you well I mean
like when people have a really Advanced
philosophy about life that is so many
components by the plane that's actually
a very simple method I think that
especially when it comes to
relationships the keys are very very
simple they're very like Bas level
things but some some dudes want to
complicate it to be so much of a Quantum
science that like they're just they're
more taking credit for like having an
advanced way of looking at it versus
like the key is just to look how
intelligent I am yeah mental
masturbation [__] exactly yeah yeah
yeah they're just jerking off to their
own theories I'm intellectual honestly
if you just approached it with a
wholesome very innocent like way that
like satisfies your you know whoever you
are inside or your inner child or
whatever it's probably going to be okay
yeah but some dudes are like no you have
to look at it this way and that way in
order to be happy it's like women are
always trying to get something from you
you know like they start exactly yeah I
feel like the more he
some the more heady someone is um the
more they're avoidant of dealing with
their own like feelings and issues like
harsh truths yeah cuz then once you
address all of that you live relaxed it
should be easy after that yeah it
doesn't matter plus sometimes somebody
just believes something so hard no
matter what no matter what you tell them
you're just like hey man like I I don't
know why it doesn't get through to you
but this isn't the way that you think it
is just because you you're cling
Clinging On to a couple things are maybe
half true yeah like what this guy does
oh [__] what did you grab that like this
is just like egregious it's
like takes a couple of things turn that
into advice what kind of advice can we
give him I mean he just takes a couple
of things and then it becomes his whole
life story it's like yeah I hate how
after he watched Loose Change he SW like
he was like they they stole my idea
Loose Change doesn't even say that it
didn't happen yeah he he takes it to a
whole another level lose change actually
tries to disassociate themselves from
Anthony Lee they're like this guy takes
a little too far we don't side with him
lose change probably has the most
footage the shows that did happen yeah
loose Chang is like we also distance
ourselves from all the violence he's
calling for and all that that's what he
gets for not being here man yeah he
thinks it's all CGI which is so crazy do
you guys still have people in your lives
that try to like they mean well and they
try to give you advice and they try to
like tell you like like how to live and
stuff my mom yeah my parents your mom
still telling you stuff well like yeah
cuz I think I don't know if it's like
[__] a Asian Jean or some [__] she
can't [__] turn it off and like kind
of like what Steve was saying like the
people that give the worst advice are
the ones that um don't really listen uh
they just they just make up your life
for and they're just I think they're
trying to just like have some sort of
catharsis of their own like fixing their
making their own lives whole justifying
their own mistakes yeah so like uh like
I think like my mom like texted G Gio
something like oh so you guys thinking
about having another kid or whatever and
then gi's like you know we gave it a
year and uh if it didn't actually happen
I think we're good she goes nah you guys
aren't dude and then she'll be like no
I'm 40 like you know the chances of any
crazy stuff happening with uh you know
um birth yeah like birth whatever can
can increase she goes oh 40 still young
man and it's just like are you even
listening always be closing
but in her brain ABC in her brain it's
probably like man I wish I had two Bots
or three bots of fall you know so I know
they want more ERS that's for sure you
know but it's like rooted but [__]
listen to what the [__] going on right
it's not that you don't it's just that
it didn't happen and you guys put you
guys made a rule and you're like that's
the rule that's it plan yeah it's always
parents she never listens I don't know
why my parents they they always tell me
oh don't eat this don't do that that but
I'm like it's okay but parents kind of
get a pass right a little bit they do
yeah cuz their information is no
pass dude yeah no it but what is
rewarding is when they would tell you
something and you go actually here's new
information about this specific thing
and then you kind of correct them oh my
God I would get shot in the face usually
you would think they would reject it but
lately my parents they they started
accepting these newer ideas they're
evolving I don't know I just I was very
stubborn I was like no this is what's
right like no you can't eat this you
just can't eat too much of this or
something like that dude let's Go's on
top baby [__] all right my mom um she
was just hanging out with us for
Thanksgiving which is like she hasn't
been to my house at all in Vegas school
ni so then she was like dude my mom
hovers I'm like trying to cook my mom's
hovering the whole F you're going to
[__] that up aren't you Stephen yeah and
I'm like okay I'm not you I'm like I
forgot what this was like but then oh
you [__] that up why using that pan
you're burning the salad don't use that
pan all that stuff and then at one
moment she saw me like crack in an egg
and she's like stepen let me show you
how to do that and I was like you're a
[__] idiot all this stuff and then
she takes two eggs she's like she's like
look you take two eggs you you push them
you bump them together and one of them
always cracks and one of them always
doesn't and I was like that's actually
really good advice cuz like I always
crack it against the side of the pan and
then sometimes and then sometimes the
egg fluid leaks on the stove and N
bitching about it later and Nikki's like
looks like you C all over the
stove and then you know I'm like I know
clean it up sorry it's two eggs just two
eggs boom but then one of them cracks so
both of them never crack at the same
time so then you just take another egg
when you want to crack the other egg and
then you put it back in the what if you
only have one egg left dude it's because
one arm's stronger than the other arm
wow I always just [__] crack it like
that yeah I yeah me too but that or I
crack it on the side of the pan I was
like that's a really good piece of
advice that I cuz I keep on [__] up
sometimes there's gold in there huh
that's it yeah you got to be open was
99% of complaining and bitching and
criticizing and then you get 1% of gold
I was dismissive initially I was being
the hater because she had been doing the
hover [__] for [__] an hour and a
half and then I got a little nug out of
it little tiny nug D yeah and changed my
egg game I crack eggs like a [__] Pro
now D I think I still got some healing
to do cuz I'll never let my mom win just
yet even if the egg [__] was right no
like even like when we like I I'll grab
dinner with her and she's like can you
work with Mommy uh back to like the the
house because it's dark and Mommy's
scared or whatever I'm like sure and
I'll walk out like this I'll protect you
and then all the neighbors are like why
is that grown dude like [__] pretending
like I'm like I'll protect you Mom oh
there's bad guys everywhere you stop
it I just have to like everything she
does I got to like turn it around and
and [__] rub it in somehow what if
she's like what if she's like Bart look
at this listing a duplex for 50,000
would you be like I'm not buying that
piece of [__] let me see let me
see the numbers make sense yeah yeah
what if there were some dudes in the
bushes and they're like oh [__] yeah
let's go rob this little Asian lady and
all [__] and then they're like that
guy's [__]
crazy they're scared of you just wait
we're just going to wait there's a guy
with a finger gun fallowing you that's
too
crazy